mais pourquoi j'avais acheté et ce tissu
au sentier celui-là chez bungie moule et
dieu bénisse
en tout cas elle sara lee que les
vacances étaient où c'est à juan les
pins non alors j'étais au match qu'on
vous dira plus tard le matin j'étais aux
antilles aux antilles ils nous regardent
tous là bas en décembre
ils me disent tous l'argent alors avec l
argent j'ai dû faire un prêt sur 18 ans
et ses beaux celui-là vous aimez bien
dieu bénisse un abraham très bronzé très
sympa et dieu m'a dit je vois qu aux
antilles on mange bien justement et sont
ouverts c'est sûr que des couples à la
rédac
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mon sacha fait
longtemps mais oui il doit avoir du gros
dossiers alors cyril lundi c'était la
rentrée
ouais et vous deviez qui fait que les
téléspectateurs adorent et les
retrouvailles bien sûr sauf qu'un
élément n'est venu perturber ces
retrouvailles
figurez vous que cet élément
perturbateur à intéresser les plus
grands producteurs à la fois de france
d'europe mais aussi du monde
figurez vous qu'ils veulent en faire un
film et ils ont même créé la bande
annonce une nasse ils attendent juste
une chose votre feu vert votre aval de
signature regardez on est sur une très
très grosse production de séries calais
lancement c'est énorme
à l'aube de l'année 2021 alors que tpm
pays s'apprête à faire sa rentrée en
direct un drame se produit remettons en
cause des heures de travail tout le
monde le dit donc à vérifier sa [ __ ]
tout ça pour un problème de son
l'incroyable jakup toutes les cinq
minutes de son ya un gros problème
notion aux lotions la leçon est champion
ou pas là à quoi doit-on s'attendre si
ce n'est au pire les chéris des gros
gros problème de son ce soir je suis
vraiment désolé soutenue dans cette
épreuve par les chroniqueurs mobilisés
tu dis que je vais donc dire je me rend
l'antenne je vais pas les missions dans
ces conditions les mecs
l'animateur pakistanais préféré du paf
va-t-il réellement rendre l'antenne une
chose est sûre c'est qu'il ne sortira
pas indemne de cette émission avec cyril
hanouna
il essaye un troisième secours
et un mec qu'on sait même pas qui c'est
pour ça qu'on les aime y'a un mec qui
descend c'est pas qui c'est
la régie d'hermach bientôt au cinéma on
fait le maximum et c'était alexandre
israël a bien sûr liberty sport s'est
vite oui serré pour cette nouvelle année
j'ai encore réuni tout ce qui se passe
pendant les pubs pendant les magnétos
puisque vous savez on ne peut rien
cacher aux téléspectateurs je suis lundi
que surveille tout et je dénonce tout et
j'ai réuni tout ça dans une seule
pastilles qui est devenu la star du paf
savait comment s'appelle 50 secondes
inside tp
salut à tous et bonne année les loups
bienvenue dans 50 secondes inside tpp
visiblement baba n'a pas assez mangé
pendant les fêtes
il a très faim mais j'avais pas gênante
pas ce soir j'ai bouffé un cul
[Musique]
esch telle ou telle et qui dort
m
visiblement en 2021 baba n'est jamais
rassasié qu'est ce que tu fais est en
train de devenir complètement fou si
j'en ai tout bouffer qu on retrouve
notre ami nicolas pernikoff qui a
toujours six mille deux cents ans le
gars qui s'appelle mi championnat et on
continue avec nicolas pernikoff cabinet
comme boukatif a ni bons voisins pour
delphine wespiser s'est tournée pour
parler d'elle
il faut jouer la montre elle a deux
qualités que bronzage et la danse
qui ont le rythme dans la peau
aucun du sixième est ce qu'après n'ont
rien fait
paquette gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement lui aussi adorent le
dancefloor puis un référentiel il a
vraiment très très faim cette année que
d'évidence bout pdq je pense très fort
ça oui lors du dernier indique en
décembre 2020 du coup je vous ai montré
que benjamin castaldi ici présents se
prenaient beaucoup de vent oui c'est le
roi des vents il en est mais il en prend
en 2021 c'est pire c'est pas des vents
qui se prend ses désirs à gand mishkin
ouvriers avant moi on va regarder
desclaux povo benji
du poil le premier fan de kansas city a
beau numéro un pour durer longtemps
[Musique]
mais l'hommage à sow
si kim l'onu juste avant j'ai du mal à
son tour avec l'oiseau
[Musique]
ce geste
on s'est mis à faire des critiques
[Musique]
pas des vents c'est parce qu on est dans
le sas or de magnéto donc on peut pas
lui répondre
c'est toujours pareil il faut qu'on
écoute voilà mais on l'est mais ni
d'autre chose
oui cyril cette année pour être encore
plus proche de vos téléspectateurs
qu'est ce que vous avez fait et bien
depuis lundi vous diffusez vos réunions
en direct ici rassure instagram rast'art
sur vous faites de la naïve mais on va
pas se mentir cyril s'est pas trop des
réunions de travail
c'est plus la face quand même ça bosse
ouais c'est plus du centre de vacances
quoi regarder vous allez voir ce que
c'est un vrai centre de bâton par et
pour ceux qu'on part gardé à puisque moi
jamais j'étais à côté j'ai tout observer
et j'ai ramené toutes les images
regarder les réunions de serre il sait
plus ce que mana et on commençait de gaz
et de la rédac avec lionel stan
directeur général qui était dans une
réunion très importante
sauf quand j'ai tiré la cote et bah
c'est pas très facile il ya trente mille
personnes
[Musique]
et qu'en syrie le fait la nouvelle année
avec ses équipes
ça fait pin bam boum qui veut faire un
petit d'heure de jeu
en 2021 tpm pessah sera médias et
stylisme stylisme compris que je tombais
redmond est complètement folle donc oui
attention ça pique un jeu très pas de
plus vers des abris dans la société on a
lu j'ai des grosses loupes l'on fait des
gros moments
ce soir je veux tout le monde surtout
les plus grands créateurs de ces gardes
à venir
[Musique]
quoi ça sert c'est le moins bon en vrai
les réunions avec céline c'est quand
même beaucoup de boulot non je déconne
j'ai compté dans la normale
wen jiabao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
enfin poteau bien sûr lundi matin 10h
pour le live instable pour la prochaine
réunion merci c'est en sache où elle a
exercé mon chéri